Hi everyone, I'm Stefani this is Johannes
we're both really happy to be here
today and more happy to see two awesome talks
with still
enough energy for a third talk, also talking
about
offline. So today we'd like to share our experience
building an off line verification for our
clients. And this guy his name is Lucas, he's
also a colleague of us, and a former project
member and we pack‑‑ we captured his
priceless face when our client came to ask
us if we could build an offline verification.
So we're all developers, and of course as
a developer when you hear about offline you
think about oh, my gosh there's going to be
data conflicts how do we synchronize them,
still data upgradeability and how do we even
test this? But, of course, we don't want to
be overly dramatic, we like to solve some
challenges and we headed out there to have
a look at the HTML5 storage technologies and
see what's out there for us, and then we thought
maybe it's not a developer's nightmare maybe
it's a nice little challenge to solve. So
before we step into talking about what we
did for our clients, we'd like to explore
a bit what offline actually means for us.
So for us offline is way more than the T‑Rex
in a Chrome browser, it's not just having
no connection at all, it's also have a very
poor internet connection, imagine going on
the tube and being connected via GPRS or just
walking around and losing con flexion to one
router and have a little very short connection
loses until you're connected to the next router
again. So when we talk about offline, that's
all these scenarios that should cover all
these scenarios. And then you might ask yourself
why? Why do we need to build anoffline capable
web application if we is have desktop applications
or just have most of the time connections.
It was not just one client it was two that
came and asked if we could build an offline
capable‑‑ that was the two case studies
that we'd like to talk about today and share
experiences, so first of all it was M Morrison
in the UK and they came to our colleagues
and they want God from paper base ordering
to telebase ordering, the store managers had
a big bunch of papers walking around the store
and checking how many products were still
in stock and they would update and place orders
based on how many they had in stock, for that
they wanted to use tablets now. They didn't
want to commit to a technology at first which
is why they wanted to build a HTML5 application.
Why did they need offline. Super market is
not the best way to ensure WiFi connection,
it's very big and they have very small connection
drops while walking around and losing connection
to one router, and second of all they have
big metal shelves, which is also not very
helpful with internet connection, and third
they also had that very big walk‑in freezers
where they keep all the dairy products milk
and cheese. They're very good at keeping the
cold in and good at keeping the WiFi out.
They needed something and it was more about
robustness of their software while placing
orders in the store. And the second project
we'd like to talk about today, that's the
project, the both of us are working on right
now. It's about a big retail client in Germany
and they have that product the travel product
testers, so what they do they specified the
products that they want to build and then
usually one of a couple of their employees
take the specification and in the system with
them and they go right to the manufacturer's
site and take products that they want to sell
right off the production line, sample products,
they take pictures of them and see if they
would fit what they specify in the the documentation
before. So they take pictures and notes and
say if their products should be sold later
on and bought. For that, usually, they don't
have WiFi connection at all in those manufacture
halls so they travel, they take the documents
with them, they don't have‑‑ maybe don't
have internet connection for about two weeks,
go back home and want to synchronize those
documents with the colleagues that have been
working on at this time. So that's a the two
scenarios that we're going to talk about today
and how we solve this. And you might ask yourself
how did we do this? Yeah, that's very nice
question and we tried to put this into three
different steps that we wanted to‑‑
that we needed to solve in order to make our
application work offline. How do you get your
client available offline? How do you install
your software in the browser? Then the data
available offline, of course, and we already
heard a bit about this in Patricia's talk.
And also data changes, how do we handle those
synchronization conflicts.
Okay, so, let's start with getting the client
off line so client off line means getting
your whole application off line, the whole
web application, all the CSS, all the images
all the JavaScript and all the HTML, and there
are two technologies how to do that and the
older one and a little bit the simpler one
application cache. Application cache works
like this, you specify a manifest file in
your main HTML file. And this file says to
my web application, I need this JavaScript,
these HTML files, this CSS files and then
your browser will detect that, install that
into a separate form of cache and the next
time your user will go to this very page and
independently if you're offline online it'll
serve off of that cache rather than off the
internet. This works really fine if you're
building a single page application, but it
has a lot of caveats when you're building
a multi‑page application, also it's not
very flexible. There's one way it's working,
and if this way is working for you, like it's
actually working for us, use application cache.
If not there's a little bit more sophisticated
thing and this is called Service Worker. It's
created buy a guy from Google named Jake Archibald.
This is somewhat like a programmable cache.
So you have this supervisors worker and it's
JavaScript file and it works in the background
of any tab which is going to your domain so
independent of how many tabs are open it's
just one Service Worker. And this Service
Worker is able to interject HTTP codes coming
from your App. If you do a request, you will
go through the Service Worker and the Service
Worker might go to the internet, if there's
internet, and just get all the stuff for you,
and then, it can also put it into the cache.
The thing is, you program the thing yourself.
So you can reroute stuff, you can read out
of the cache, you can invalidate the cache
you're doing all of this yourself, rather
than the automatic model, which is the model
you have with application cache. Depending
on what your needs are, chose one of them,
application cache is a bit older, it's supported
on most modern browsers, Service Worker is
only kind of ready in Chrome. So make your
choice and find something.
Whoo we're already one third through, now
you may want to know how to get the data available
offline. And, actually our colleague from
the UK, the Morrisson example they use web
storage to store the data offline. There are
two version of web storage, local storage
and web storage, very icy to use and very
nice. A big break through was when they thought
in terms of‑‑ when they thought about
their updates in terms of commands, they knew
I want to update this product with a quantity,
a product ID and I need to store nit a queue
in case I get‑‑ in case I lose connection
I still have that available. For them they
used local storage and it worked very fine.
In our project, we couldn't use local storage,
basically for three reasons. First of all,
we're developing for Chrome only and in Chrome
the local storage has only 5 MB and that was
simply not enough. Our users specification,
big documents with tables text and images
in them. For us that was simply not enough
space. And second of all, as you might have
guessed in next DB‑‑ I believe decked
DB, we wanted queries, we wanted to know give
me some specification that has been written
in that from date X to date Y so we wanted
to place those queries and that was also possible
within index DB. Another thing was that actually
at the beginning we didn't use index DB we
used local storage at a certain point our
data got messed up and we asked ourselves
why. Until we released how our users use their
application, they opened our application in
multiple tabs and working in them at the same
time. And then, they were all writing for
the same storage and our data got messed up.
Therefore, we wanted something that gives
us locking transaction, which index DB gives
us. Because with this scenario our single
threaded JavaScript suddenly became multi‑threaded.
Yes, that's how we used it. And another interesting
point, as we found, was migration, that was
something that we didn't really tackle from
the beginning, and at some point we had to,
of course, index DB is Schemaless and we're
running Java on the back end, there's no other
reason than the client wants it. They're both
scheme maless, but we're having a Schema that
lives in our application, and we need to clean
that up from time to time. So if we have migration
going on, of course migration number 42, first
of all what we do when our context starts
we do my grate all the data on our Mongodb,
as soon as the client connects, for us, with
application cache, we do have a new version
then and ship them all an application code,
with this application we ship migrationjs
file so the client can migrate it's own data
in the index DB. But one more interesting
point is that we actually didn't want to write
the same migration code in JavaScript and
Java, we wanted to share that kind of that
piece of business logic so therefore we used
something called Naser. You may know it by
rhino, and that's a Java engine that lets
you execute JavaScript in the back end, that
worked really fine for us. That was okay to
set up and now works since we started doing
migrations. Yeah.
Okay, finally how do you handle data changes.
Data changes can come in two different flavors,
and interesting enough you can both solve
them with a gang of 4 pattern. Done for on
the radio. One of them is the command pattern,
and the other one is the mow men toe pattern.
And if you're lucky you can use the command
pattern, and that's what the people at Morrissons
could use. So, how did they do it? Actually,
when someone is walking around the super market,
they will, like, detect, oh, there's not enough
Museli at that place, I need to update that
order so I get more Muslie. So they update
the order and they press a button, and by
pressing that button they do an action. And
this action can be captured into an object.
Which is then called the update order command.
So when you have those objects with an action
you can get a sequence of the actions the
user does and you simply store them in a local
storage. Or in "the" local storage in this
form. They just put them into local storage,
when ever Annette connection is available,
they send the command over the wire and the
server had a message processor where they
store the data into the database. It's not
really relevant how the message processor
looks like, so either you apply the commands
to your data and then you have like the end
state in your database or you store even the
commands and you do events sourcing and only
apply the commands on read, but whatever you
do, that's a pretty clean way to do synchronizations,
so when ever you have the chance in an application
where you have distinct commands to do synchronization,
I would try to use commands for that because
it's pretty clean, the user has an idea if
a command fails because if you say hey, I
couldn't update that order because there was
already someone else who update the order,
they have a connection to the conflict. But
unfortunately, our users are writing documents,
so our changes look rather like this. So our
users are not programmers so they don't know
<div>es, there's really a hard way, they just
type ahead and every change done to the documents
is like a letter typed. So this is simply
impossible to do with commands because the
only type of command you would have is updated
document, update the document, update the
document. So this is not something you can
work with. So how do you do that? You create
kind of your chain sets, you do that by a
pattern called momento which works like I
have a state of my document () and I remember
that (Momento) and five seconds later there's
a new state of my document and I remember
that. And these states can be transferred.
So, for us it's five second, it can be any
number. You have to chose what is fitting
for you. How does that work? So first of all
the user types and when ever he types we're
having an Angular application you can do it
with everything, it goes through a JavaScript
component called Repository. This Repository
immediately writes into the indexDB so every
key stroke the user dozeneds up in indexDB
like in one document like in the sequence
of documents. And then Repository says, Hey
something change in the the database with
this document and it tells this information
to another component also written in JavaScript
called the queue, you can name it whatever
you want, we call it the queue. And this creates
itself something in the indexDB which is like
saving the changes or documented the changes
done to your database. And in this case, you
have an item, with the UID and it's in stage
queued, it's waiting to be synchronized the
changes in this together are waiting to be
synchronized. We wait for five seconds after
these five seconds it will start sinking that
document. So it will change the stage to insink,
so it knows this document is currently sinked,
I should not sink it again, if the sinking
process takes longer than five seconds. And
it tells the document Repository go ahead
and save that to the internet, because the
queue doesn't know about the internet the
queue just knows about changes. And what happened
is because sometimes the internet is slow
the user is still typing, there are still
changes while on the other end someone is
sinking so it's just queuing it again. So
it's queued and insink at the same time, and
the changes currently done will be synced
with the five second cycle. That's all interestmenting,
I said five seconds. Five seconds is actually
not that easy to detect if you have a business
application where users write documents and
usually they have more than one document open.
More than one document means more than one
engine accessing the database. And you don't
want to sync on all the that tabs you have,
we were thinking how to do that, Service Worker
would be a good way to do it because you only
have one per tab, another way to do it is
share web workers, because share web workers
are like web workers just between all the
tabs. So we have a timer in our shared web
worker which at random choses one tab and
you do the sync every five seconds the same
it's just random. The other thing and Stefie
had nit the beginning on one of the slides,
when are we actually off line? So don't go
for the navigator.offline property on your
browser, because in Chrome it just tells you
you're connected to any internet that's not
helping you. Are you connected to "the" internet
as a whole, but our servers down, that's alsooffline.
Offline is when you can't connect to your
own back end, that's the definition we chose,
and the users want to know when they're off
line, because it's important if their data
is synced or not T shared web worker pings
our server, hey, are you still there, and
the server responds, yes, yes, all the time
or not. The web worker will tell all the tabs,
hey, you're offline or your online so the
user knows in every tab the state of the application
and if it's currently thinking or not.
Yeah, let me quickly check the type. Yep.
(Laughs) nice. So yeah, what is it now? Is
this building an offline capable verification
a developer's nightmare or a nice little challenge
to solve. As a good consultant, I'm going
to tell you that depends. But I can‑‑
we'd like to share you some questions that
we asked ourselves that helped us to determine
what technology would fit best for our cases.
And how we determined what it would be worth
spending time on or not. First of all it's
the size of the data, for example the Morrison
example the local storage was enough for them.
It's way easier to use something synchronous
than having to tale with the whole DB API,
so the size of data matters, also the structure
of data we were really lucky that our data
didn't have much dependencies, but if you
have a lot of dependencies in your data you
might want to change to a different storage
technology. And it also makes sense that your
storage technologies kind of matches, so we
used index DB and MongoDB it worked really
well together, if you have to use relational
database you might want to think something
else. There's something called web SQL, which
is deprecated and I don't have much experience
in it, but that's maybe something you want
to consider. Another one is a potential for
data conflicts, in both cases we're really
lucky our clients said data conflicts are
not something that should occur often. Socially
the store managers update the products in
the store only on their own, so there's no
two people standing in the same aisle and
updating stuff. Also one person should work
on a document even though it can happen that
two people work on the same one, but we should
only be able to detect the conflict and not
have a sophisticated conflict resolution.
Which you could do here. We're on a level,
we saw that we could show sophisticated <div>
or even do auto personalling, browser support
is a big one, our application was only supposed
to run in Chrome, so we were really lucky.
That's not always the case, but there's some
technologies that are just not, not working
or supported by old browsers. And the very
obvious one, but a very one that you should
remember is the amount of functionality to
work offline. For both applications, not the
full application worked offline, only the
core functionality that they really needed
was working offline. Another thing is we're
now‑‑ we're now having users for about
a year and there's some more challenges. We
only talked about the challenges that we had
while implementing the software but not really
what happened when we went live in production.
So there's still two challenges that are need
to be solved and one of them is the storage
management. Our data's way too large to put
it all on the client side, so what to we do?
What do we do when the our indexDB is full.
We already heard in Patricia's talk she had
a slide where she visualized how Chrome manages
your storage so you get half of the available‑‑
oh she had a third of the available memory
that you have on your machine and therefore
every application gets maximum of 20percent.
So what does our user do when they travel
for two weeks? Of course they sit in an airplane
for a very long time so they don't load a
bunch of Dr.Who episodes and then there
machine is full, their available hard drive
shrinks and therefore they don't have much
space to have those documents available offline.
So this is still a challenge that we're trying
to solve. How do we make it easy for the users
to decide when they want to have the documents
available offline and when can they be deleted
and not just randomly let them delete by Chrome.
Another thing is local data versus non‑local
data. Our users, as we saw before, have duplication
open in multiple tabs, so what they do is
they start writing a document then switch
to another document and to another tab and
want to search for what they just added immediately.
But as Johannes said before we have that five
seconds delay until it synchronize was the
back end and a third is only place in the
the back end. So it's kind of awkward for
them that they have to wait five seconds until
they can search for what they just entered.
So, what we're thinking of right now is having
actually a search that searches not only the
back end but also locally and then Americans
those results together to give our users a
bit better user experience as well using our
software. And yeah. That's it. Thanks. (Applause).